which is the lines,
Dan Campbell the Detroit Lions.
We've been watching them all
year riding. We're always saying
they are playing good
team stuff. And now you're
starting to see them when they
just beat Arizona.
Man. This is week 15 when we 15
and we're still seeing a lines
play hard to me. That just shows
how much respect they
have for Dan, Campbell. They
know if
you know Dan Campbell as a
player
you knew that he was a tough
guy. He fought, he claw,
you know all about biting a
tank.
Eagles. But it just shows me
that they have a level of
respect for this guy. In order
for them to take that next
step. They're going to have to
upgrade their roster.
And what does that mean? They're
going to have to get
free agents to come to Detroit.
How do you get free agents to
come to Detroit? You don't, if
you got a great quarterback,
which they don't have,
you got to overpay guys. So if
it's me I'm going to get guys
that can make a difference like
a Chris Godwin. You might have
to overpay for him to go, you
know,
come to the team or, you know, a
safety like Marcus Williams.
If the Saints, don't decide. The
Pam. You got the bring
impact players in here
and to Detroit surrounding with,
you know, just surround
these impact players, you know,
with the talent that you
already have and see what
happens. But nobody wants to
come to Detroit if you're not
going to overpay and that's
what they're going to have to
do. They have to
get some more talent and
overpay.
There's some Cornerstone pieces.
When you watch this
team, watch that Arizona game.
They have good tackle play
really good, tackle play between
Taylor Decker and pain
a soul and that takes you a long
way. Now, you just need
average, guys in the interior
that offensive line DeAndre
Swift. He's a young running back
that I think has star
potential. Then you look at a
bomb on Rusty, Brown, who
I went to Notre Dame, with his
brother Equanimity of st. Brown
and he's the better version. He
went to USC.
He became a fourth-round pick,
but he's their leading receiver
all year long and TJ Hawkinson.
The tight end who's going to
miss the rest of this season,
but when he comes back, he's
a darn good tight end. So,
that's some pieces. If you add
an extra receiver, like you're
talking about,
could be something there and it
probably happened.
You have to add two more. You
probably don't have to add two
more receivers a little bit more
depth at the tight end
position and more depth at the
running back position. But
where your focus needs to be is
on a defensive line.
Getting those pass rushers and
making sure you have corners.
I know they have the young
Corner out there. Number 24. I
forget
how to say his name, forgive me,
but he's a good young player. I
think he had an interception
this past Sunday, but they're
going to have to get like
a stud free safety in there. A
guy that can really come in and
control, you know. The defense.
So just add a few more pieces,
and we'll see a few more
victories next year.